albon soir monsieur l'euro pour s'ouvrir
dans tuant profuse donc de publier ses
déclarations de revenus prétexte
prétextant qu'elles sont sous enquête en
ce moment est-ce qu'il a raison de
décider de faire ça non le contribuable
peut toujours choisir de divulguer
d'informations toutefois l'agent du
groupe d'amérique n a pas le droit de
publier les formations alors que le
contribuable i love ce pouvoir et
qu'alors que c'était la tradition depuis
carabins trompe décidé de faire
autrement il dit voilà il ne payer que
705 750 dollars en 2016 en 2007 et même
chose alors que abraham blinken enduit
ça se faisant les quatre avaient payé
1200 $ défaut à ce moment là me trompe
ou revoir 2016 dans quelques 750 $ tel
incident alors est ce que il ne cherche
à cacher des informations à ne pas venir
confirmer l'information que le new york
times dit avoir et avoir donc publié le
président je vous rappel ni les
informations affirmant que ce sont de
fausses nouvelles
il dit que ce sont des forces nouvelles
puis ensuite il dit que c'était obtenues
légalement mais c'est chose est certaine
ce que le new york times a publié ce est
prélevée à même les informations
proviennent des déclarations même de 30
et non pas de qu'en dira-t-on donc denis
martin j'ai obtenu les formations et
puis bah voilà on effets de la crise ils
ont travaillé fort et voilà six courses
a donc est ce qui ressort aussi c'est
que c'est qu'elle trempe finalement se
fout totalement de l'équité fiscale du
devoir de chacun de payer sa juste part
des pots et lui entre autres il a
utilisé bon une perte de 1 milliard de
dollars qui l'a fait lorsque le casino
d'atlantic cité affirmé et il convient
si cette porte-là en un crédit d'impôt
personnel de 72 millions de dollars ce
qui est servi à éponger tous les revenus
ou à peu près tous les revenus pour
lesquelles il aurait payé de l'impôt
à la suite de son sa télé réalité the
apprentice
allez y avait permis aux épaules avec ce
crédit alors
résultat des courses il faut payer des
boues à peu près depuis 15 ans dit
apprentice qui est extrêmement populaire
téléréalité ou
ou donald trump congédier des gens là
hier c'était très populaire il a touché
beaucoup d'argent avec ça et donc il a
exercé des pertes sur cet argent qu'il
avait touché à ce moment là c'est ça
c'est ça fait et la perte de la vente du
casino
il est utilisé à ces fins personnelles
l'arrêt perte de ce casino 1
et puis donc la ferme de 1 milliard qui
le convertit en au crédit d'impôt dans
diminution de sa facture personnel
d'impôt pour 72 millions et ceux ci
c'est contester présentement par l'agent
du rouble est américaine et donc l'objet
de contestations bien sûr ses pairs ce
litige
ça va donner lieu à un paiement d'impôts
par trompe de plus de 100 millions de
dollars
et donc on peut voir un peu ce qu'il
décide donc tu remplis à 100 millions de
dollars d'impôts potentiels médaillables
il est aussi au bâton pour 300 millions
$ de dettes personnelles qui la garante
si pour ces 500 entreprises donc et 3,5
millions de dollars battant donc ça fait
près 400 millions de dollars d'aidé de
potentiel et ses 3,5 millions de dollars
us est payable au cours des quatre
prochaines années
donc on s'entend que les quatre
prochaines années c'est un nouveau
mandat de président et donc trop belle
que les gars il est je me fais rire je
vais faire en sorte qu étant élu les
personnes et créé ainsi à qui je dois de
l'argent
ces gens là peut-être qu'on voit est en
mesure de négocier un arrangement parce
que les créanciers voudront-ils
poursuivre un président loin d'être
certaine et on ne sait pas qui sont
rentrés en si on ne sait pas c'est ça
donc cette personne là est ce que ce
sont des banquiers est-ce que sur des
pays étrangers parce que beaucoup il ya
des centaines de millions de dollars de
pertes fiscales dans tout ça ici le lait
des pertes fiscales pour en avoir il
faut avoir dépensé plus que ce qu'on a
gagné
alors pour dépenser faut avoir de
l'argent d'où vient son argent est-ce
que ça viendrait peut-être de pays
étrangers
est-ce que ça m'aiderait de la russie
peut-être et c'est pour ça que trump est
toujours très gentil avec moi mon avis
avec certains dirigeants étrangers comme
par exemple 30 à 13 millions de dollars
avec les royautés promenade sur cris et
32 10 km
gales c'est son grand champ donc il veut
pas perdre ses trois ces voyous tu es là
il pas déplaire à ses étrangers non plus
et c'est pour ça que nancy pelosi la
leader démocrate je comprends qu'ils
aient bien sûr le jeu politique
démocrate républicain mais indique que
l'enjeu de la dette personnelle du
président c'est aussi un enjeu de
sécurité nationale
parce que s que es con mais est ce que
le président peut mettre dans la balance
son enjeu d'endettement un retour de
certains privilèges qu'ils accorderaient
à des dirigeants étrangers par exemple
écouter dans la mesure où 4000 au cours
des quatre prochaines années il se
devait de 400 millions payables il est
incapable de payer
de quelle façon peut-être pour essayer
de les payer en octroyant des bénéfices
provenant de l'état américain à ses
créanciers pour frc ça proprement ces
points possibles pour lui la politique
est une télé réalité il ce fut carrément
du reste plus que 8 mai m'a sorti
gagnant la démonstration est très claire
andré lareau merci beaucoup je remercie